to cross over to the Turkish president
of Davido and who's addressing a press
conference at the moment
the north of Syria has been also
affected and the damage was also there
our country since the very beginning of
the earthquake has
worked hard
and
within each given rate
the work was massive and huge
and the mayors of these government rates
have been assisted by other more Mayors
and all that to help and support those
in need our institutions are quite
concerned with this catastrophes also
the Turkish armed forces and other
institutions in Turkey
which has experiences and this
connection have been summoned to work in
these government rates our priority is
to rescue those in need 9
000 elements are working now hard to
rescue and to continue the risky
operations
the Govern rates that have been hugely
affected by this
earthquake and the results and the
rubberus also need a lot of work and
support even by the citizens since the
very first
moment of the earthquake we were in
contact
with the local
and concerned authorities and agencies
in Ankara as well the coordination
Center in Ankara has quickly moved under
the chairmanship of the vice president
the ministers went to the government in
order to supervise the risky operations
at the place
since the very beginning
those govern rates affected and the
governorates that are
a little bit affected have been also in
contact with us according to a major
plan to distribute the rescue teams all
over the place
and this winter the weather is very cold
and the people of turkey are also in
coordination with all of us
in order to stop the escalation of the
disaster everyone has done his job
quickly and as soon as possible we will
continue our efforts at the same time
because
the those who are killed and those who
are injured
and this the buildings that have been
destroyed are huge to
1800 buildings have been destroyed and
collapsed in this in these govern rates
and
the risky operation is ongoing and we
don't know exactly the
figures will Mount and will be
escalating to what extent
we need to work and to do our best in
order to continue in contact with these
areas
and consequently
Communications and contacts must be
always there and available means of
transportation must always work and
individuals and institutions working
there in the disasters area must be in
complete contact and coordination
with the concerned authorities we need
no more chaos and we need to provide
those in need with the assistances
when it comes to the international help
and Aid we have our contact with other
countries in addition to Nato and
European Union there are 45 countries
that have requested to help us in this
disaster
may Allah Almighty bestow his Mercy on
those who lost their lives and may Allah
so as Mercy on the injured and wounded
we as a country and as a people in
complete Harmony and we will overcome
this problem
we will overcome this crisis
we are 85 million citizens and today is
the day of Union
our country
at this particular moment will work hard
and we all ask Allah Almighty to keep
our country safe to keep the humanity
safe and thank you very much
you're watching Al Jazeera where life
Manker the present rest of diverter and
was addressing the assembled press Corps
for an update on what's been going on
regarding the earthquake that hit the
country and also Northern Syria in the
early hours of Monday morning I mean we
did expect the president to take to the
airwaves after both the deputy Vice
President
also gave an update and we had comments
and press releases from the interior
Minister Suleiman Sulu the president
didn't give any more new details that we
haven't already heard already but
generally generalities about the
infrastructure of turkey the authorities
the armed forces the medical rescue
teams have all been deployed to those
particular areas 10 Governors or 10
provinces have been affected and the
action plan has already been in place
turkey is no stranger to these sorts of
earthquakes he's also confirmed that
International Aid and help has been
offered they are a member of NATO one of
the over 40 countries in that group and
of course I hope to Aspire to become
part of the EU the EU already offering
help let's go back to cinema casulu you
heard really what the president had to
say he said no more really sin end than
we've already heard so far but he
obviously has a very big task ahead of
him because this is perhaps an
earthquake on the scale that turkey has
never seen before
well so hell I mean the figures that the
prayer the president gave are very high
after following a vice president's
statement and two hours ago it has been
only nine hours since this earthquake
happened and the death toll has risen to
912 200
2740 people have been rescued but 5 385
people have been injured so apparently
there are so many buildings that have
been collapsed the figure is 2818 and
because of the weather conditions
apparently the rescue teams are having
difficulty to reach out to some of the
buildings or the weather conditions are
making their work very difficult but
this is this is one of the worst uh
earthquakes yes Istanbul earthquake in
1999 was almost as strong as this one
above 7.5 also as Indian earthquake in
eastern Anatolia during 90s it was also
one of those uh biggest earthquakes but
uh this earthquake impacted affected 10
cities as the fault line was close to
the surface less than eight kilometers
that's why intensities everybody was
able to fill the uh strength of this
earthquake the geology experts are
saying that the magnitude is 7.8 but
what is felt was around 11.0 magnitude
so the impact of this earthquake was
very strong and as far as we are hearing
on the reports from the witnesses that
the duration of the shake was very long
this is one of the reasons of this big
damage
the cinema of course uh the the rescue
operation continues and as you say uh
over 10 provinces affected but for our
viewers can you sort of tell us a little
bit about the terrain because there are
large urban areas in these in these
provinces to the southeast of the
country there are also vast uh arable uh
agricultural lands as well and as you
say the weather is impacting on the
potential uh help that can get to these
areas just color the picture in terms of
the type of area this is and and how
problematic it will be if you can't get
air support in the roads too will be
affected
well definitely suhail I mean turkey's
Eastern part some of the cities in
Eastern Turkey are industrialized cities
with high population relatively High
population of course you cannot compare
it to Istanbul Ankara Izmir Adana or
ansalia but within their range compared
to the standards of Eastern Anatolia
malathia is a big city the arbucker is a
big city and uh adiaman is a big city as
you said since these cities are still
agriculture cities along with some
industry the the urban structure is uh
is actually horizontal so we are talking
about a vast geography that has been
affected including the rural areas of
these provinces not only the city
centers and because of the weather
conditions for instance in gazante there
is there is snow for the last couple of
days in hatai trucia Southern coastal
city which is which is border with Syria
yesterday it snowed there is also Heavy
Rain I mean the winters are always very
very difficult in eastern Anatolia
because there is always a heavy snow
that's why President erdogan also
mentioned about carriers that should be
brought to those areas I'm reading some
reports on social media that some areas
there is no access of course this needs
to be verified and the rescue workers
are doing their best to do that but
everything all these climate conditions
make makes it very difficult to reach
out to people and even rescue operations
during normal weather conditions it's
easier to take people out but when it's
snowy or rainy all those rubbles and mud
it is making everything very difficult
that's why as soon as we heard the
Turkish interior Minister who spoke in
the early hours of this morning he said
turkey announced alarm alarm level 4
which requires International assistance
despite turkey is very experienced about
earthquakes and rescue operations and
always helps out to countries in need in
when there is when there are natural
disasters this time the personal the the
carriers will not seems to be not enough
and they will need more International
assistance to reach out to those places
we'll continue to monitor events with
you from the capital Cinema casula there
in Istanbul for us
now turkey as Vice President says the
government is in contact with several
countries to receive help
old buildings that are hosting hospitals
have been affected we are doing our best
in order to give assistance to the
people we have provided tents and camps
already in the nearby area
rescue operations have already started
and we are in contact with every
concerned party in this regard we have
also received information of so many
countries that are ready to help we have
requested medical supplies and medical
equipment now the White House has
reacted to the earthquake the National
Security adviser Drake Sullivan says the
U.S is profoundly concerned adding that
Washington stands ready to provide
assistance he said that President Biden
has directed usaid and other federal
government Partners to assess response
options to help those affected and the
U.S will continue to monitor the
situation in coordination with the
government of Turkey
well the EU is also sending rescue teams
European commission President says the
blocks members stand in full solidarity
with the people of turkey and Syria and
will continue helping in any way that
they can
Russell joins us now from Istanbul well
you heard what the president had to say
uh wrestle we've also heard what the
vice president said and also statements
from the interior Minister the
government seemed to be in fifth gear
they have to be seen to be doing all and
saying all the right things for the
Turkish public right now
indeed as well because the country is
going to hold the elections general
elections on May 14 which is going to
decide about which party is going to
form the majority in the Parliament and
also who is going to be the next
president of Turkey so in that sense it
is quite a very critical time for the
government and not only politically but
also in terms of the weather as well
just to be at the beginning of the week
so a cold wave hit the country and
particularly the southern east
Southeastern cities of the country are
witnessing Sub-Zero weather conditions
so it's quite tough and very critical
time both politically and in terms of
the weather in Turkey so president
erdogan according to many experts is
going to face the most difficult
elections throughout his political
career scale because the polls show that
the the chance of winning is almost 50
50 which is the first time maybe in
throughout his political career that
chance of losing is the this time real
but on the other hand it is regarded as
a kind of opportunity for the opposition
as well because government's failure
could work in favor of the opposition as
well so that's why your position now is
calling out the government to uh to
deliver the rescue the heart
indiscriminatively and they are saying
that today is the day of the unity
rather because considered in turkey that
is politically a very divided country
now we can see from both from government
and opposition there are the message of
the unity being sending out because any
wrongdoing here particularly during this
delicate time could hurt the nation so
that's why they're meticulously careful
about that and just in less than three
months there is going to be a very
significant election in Turkey which
according to many experts is the most
important election of 2023 so okay so
let me just jump in there let me just
jump in there for a second particularly
let me just jump in there for a second
rasul because obviously the government
and opposition want to win hearts and
Minds as you say with an upcoming
election but in terms of the affected
earthquake area who has more influence
right now what sort of sway do or what
sort of way do the people think there
about their government and the
opposition parties
but of this earthquake is that many of
the Southeastern city of Turkey have a
Kurdish majority population so their
wart is going to be quite determinative
in this election so whoever they would
in favor probably is going to win the
election so in that sense president
needs to convince the Kurdish Waters and
on the other hand opposition also is
trying to convince them so in that sense
it is quite important so it's not only
about the magnitude of the of the of the
earthquake by the way it has also been a
device it was said that it's 7.4 but now
it has been revised to 7.7 magnitude and
it's not only about the magnet but also
the area that it covers you're talking
about 10 cities and many of them are
major cities the city is like diarbaker
malathia and antep which majority of
them are Kurds are almost having around
2 million population and the other
cities is like
they have more than 2 million population
so when we talk about these provinces
these cities we are talking about the
major cities in the country that's why
it is quite a difficult task for the
government because comparing to the
previous uh the earthquakes in Turkey
this is happening in multiple cities and
it is very much difficult and delicate
for the government politically and also
in terms of the people's lives as the
number the figures of the death tolls
here is going higher and higher hour by
hour results of the forest are in
Istanbul thank you
well earlier we spoke to Heart producer
Emmanuel khatib who's in gaziantep one
of the worst affected areas he explains
what his family went through during the
earthquake
we're going through one of the heaviest
earthquakes that I've ever seen and I
think turkey also seen
that the situation was undescribable I
mean like you you don't know what is
going on and you can feel that some of
their earthquakes that I have been
witnessed before it was like you feel
that the the windows you feel the the TV
is shaking but at this time I felt the
the wall is shaking the building the
whole building was shaking it was like
it's it's
it's massive like at the moment that we
faced it I couldn't think of anything
just to put my kids under the table and
stay there until the earthquake gone and
I was wishing at that moment to be a
dream I didn't want it to be like a
truly what's happening that's what we've
seen I just wanted to be a dreamer I
start to pray at that time to be a dream
but it wasn't and after the earthquake
just finished for a second we just
picked what we can get and we moved
outside and you can see the small tents
that I had with me that I put my kids in
it and my mother was just sitting next
by the temperature is under zero it's
undescribable that's what we've got
seeing some of the building was falling
down in gazantep in Adana in karma and
marash and channel
and I've just received like a few hours
ago that my uncle and his wife and his
two children
it was just dead under one of the poorly
Apartments
so far they couldn't get them out of air
and we are still waiting just for their
bodies to be out
watching some of miserable yeah
seeing some of the images come through
um from gazian tip and uh and the other
regions that have been affected are just
absolutely horrible and it's um it's
amazing to see some of these Brave uh
search and rescue uh teams going through
the rubble especially uh with the
aftershocks that have been continuing
can you give us a sense of what it is
like because obviously some survivors of
previous earthquakes describe the
aftershocks are just as bad
um not because of the magnitude but
because of the psychological impact that
it has on people that have survived the
initial
initial earthquake how what have they
been like where you are
exactly as you said the aftershocks it's
similar to the same first one and after
we left since 4 12 until now we are just
standing outside in the cold until the
some of the mosque was opened their
doors for people to be welcomed and set
inside in warm condition many other
people don't feel safe to be inside any
building that you can see the whole
street are filled with cars and people
sitting inside it
I mean the the aftershocks in each 10 to
5 minutes
that you can feel it sometimes it's
coming so heavy that you can see like
some of the the the items inside the the
mosque is shaking the kids start
screaming that the even the the big
and elderly people start screaming like
it's it's Indescribable like I cannot I
cannot tell you that and I can't film
even they don't allow anyone to film
because of this horrible situation but
it's it's like it's just like a dream
and we wish that we go out of that dream
that we wish just to be wake up and and
how are your family doing
my family actually that we are trying to
make the kids feeling it's it's kind of
a game that's because they don't
understand it and this is the first time
they are witnessing kind of earthquake
and they'll keep asking like why we are
not going home why we are not staying at
home it's cold outside let's go home we
want to go back home and we went just
for a few minutes to the home to get
some
clothes and change their like wet
clothes and we felt like some of the
parts of the building start falling
internally and then we decide no we need
to go back outside like it's not safe
here and even they have had security
government uh
a risk Society they start sending
messages through the phone saying that
it's not safe to stay in homes go
outside to the public locations or to
the mosques
so the kids is like trying to understand
what's happening we the the Elder people
like the young people like we don't know
for who we need to have a fear on like
the kids or to ourselves or to our
parents we don't know like when it's
happened again what we should do